Since 2014, a working group has been developing
proposals for the rehabilitation of the Kaiapoi River.
Today we are on the riverbank opposite the Kaiapoi Borough School .
This is a nice part of the Kaiapoi River here Neville,
what's happening here?
What are the council planning on doing?
What we intend to do is try and plant what
used to be here.
As you can see in the background, just over
here, it used to be quite full of raupō and
oxygen weed in this whole area, right throughout
the river.
That's depleted, and we're not sure why, there's
many theories.
There's those around salt weeds, there's those
around changing conditions since the earthquakes.
We need to know the effect of sediment and
how deep, and all of those things.
We need to know the effects of what's happened
with the nitrates in the river and all of
those things that the water zone committee
concentrating on at the moment.
A lot of locals have theories around sprays,
so we the information on whether
they are making any difference.
All of that sort of science is being collected,
as well as having monitors in here to see
how much salt is being pushed back, whether
the river flows from the Waimak in here are to low
or whether indeed they are not effecting
us at all.
You've mentioned sediment, how exactly are you going deal with that,
how are you going to analyse it?
So what we want to do is dig this out, all
the sediment out of here and then put the
channels through the river so the water can
flow in the channel.
And this will collect the sediment and the
cost of actually re-dredging the river will
be a lot different to what it used to be because
you'll hopefully be able to take the sediment
from one place as opposed to right the way
down and round the river.
And we want to collect information from the
public about what would be good areas and
what's their view on this stuff as well? Not just
the science around it,
but what are they thinking as well about where these sediment traps and things should be.
Like every river in New Zealand, there's no
easy fix.
Lots of steps, lots and lots of steps to rehabilitate
and make sure we can get things back to, well,
the way they were, I'm not sure whether you can get them back to the way they were, but as close
as we can get to what had, if not better.
So how can people have their say?
Well, right here they can come in and there
will be an open day at Ruataniwha and people
can have their input that way.
We have the website, we have councillors,
community board members and we really want
people to have their input.
There are six proposals we'd like your feedback
on, attend our open day on the 27th of April
or find out more at waimakariri.govt.nz